we've all seen the videos dozens of cop
cars pulling up to a shopping mall in
Miami people running in Terror blurry
figures on the screen an alien invasion
covered up by the government and the
media here's how NBC News reported on it
quote on Monday a group of roughly 50
teenagers caused a riot at Bayside
Marketplace an outdoor mall roughly 5
miles from South Beach according to the
Miami Police Department the teens were
sitting off fireworks which led to a
panic as some assumed there was a
shooting said Miami Police Department
Public Information officer Michael Vega
four teens were
arrested huh they expect us to believe
that H here's what I want to know what
really happened I'll tell you what I
think really happened at that shopping
mall in Miami I think that what really
happened is that on Monday a group of
roughly 50 teenagers caused a riot at
Bayside Marketplace an outdoor mall
roughly five miles from South Beach
according to the Miami Police Department
the teens I believe were setting off
fireworks which led to a panic as some
assumed there was a shooting just like
the Miami Police Department says four
teens I believe were
arrested if 50 young people start
robbing
stores attacking people setting off
explosives indoors I should hope that a
lot of cops would show up the reason
that these sorts of crimes are spiking
right now is precisely because our
political leaders keep attacking the
police and preventing them from doing
their jobs that's part of why we've got
such disorder such social breakdown not
just in a mall in Miami but all
throughout the country the social
breakdown seems clearest in the riots
and the robberies and the street crime
but it has deeper Roots the breakdown of
the family the disintegration of the
education system the collapse of trust
in our most basic civil institutions
it's all been happening for a while and
it's getting worse and worse but some
people still can't believe it not here
they say no this can't really be
happening this is America we are now
more inclined to believe that aliens are
invading then that America is becoming a
third world country I'm Michael NES this
is the Michael N
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show whoopy Goldberg
says that she is on a Jeffrey Epstein
list sort of sort of we'll get to what
that means in just a second first though
I guess I should qualify my point in the
opening there is an alien invasion going
on it's not happening at the Bayside
Mall in Miami it's a little bit
happening in Miami but it's also
happening in Texas and California and
Arizona and then because of airplanes
it's happening in New York and Chicago
and Washington DC and it's not martians
it is Guatemalans and Hondurans and
salvadorians and well not Salvadorans
anymore because na B turned his country
around but a lot of places in Latin
America are opening the floodgates and
saying hey if you want to leave and go
to America Joe Biden's not going to stop
you there's graph that went viral over
the weekend it shows illegal immigrant
encounters by President and what a lot
of people are noticing they find it
striking is that Obama and Trump had
roughly the same number of encounters it
went down a little bit under Trump but
not all that much in the first year of
trump it went down pretty considerably
when Trump had been signaling for months
over a year at that point that he was
going to build a big beautiful wall and
send all the illegal aliens back and so
illegal Crossings dropped then the
illegals and the coyotes and the cartels
realized that Trump even though he was
President of the United States couldn't
actually enforce that policy he was
being totally undercut by his
administration and the bureaucracy so
the numbers went back up again it was
pretty high under Obama you're looking
at 5 million encounters
5,692 encounters under Trump was a
little bit lower but similar
4,763 7 encounters and then what about
Biden 12
million more than
double well over double what happened
under Trump more than double what
happened under Obama more than Obama and
Trump put together what's going on
here Biden wants illegal aliens to come
into the country in moments of cander he
has said as much he's said things like
we're we're not going to build a wall
surge to the Border your future dreamer
undocumented wonderful Americans but the
message has been the same come over here
even when there's a little wink and a
nod well we're going to enforce the law
eventually but no human being is illegal
and you can just come process and you'll
you'll be brought back to court someday
maybe I don't know
enjoy he says come to the country why
it's very very
simple immigrants vote Democrat not all
immigrants I hail on one side of my
family from immigrants and it's the
Italians who kind of split 50/50 you get
the scalas but you get the Pelosi
too I'm not just talking about illegal
aliens I'm not just talking about people
from Honduras or Guatemala or Mexico I'm
talking about all immigrants you take
immigrants as a whole legal
illegal they vote for
Democrats according to one survey from
the uh Kaiser Family
Foundation all immigrants are twice as
likely to identify as Democrats as as
Republicans and a lot of Republicans
don't want to acknowledge this they
don't want to get down to the bare
political reality of why the Democrats
want Mass migration which is to to
fundamentally change the structure of
our constitutional republic illegally
totally against the law totally
unconstitutional but they they they
realize that they've got an advantage
and they think that the Republicans are
so afraid of being unjustly called
racists that we're not going to say
anything about
it so that's the one side you've got the
cowardice from the Republicans who say
well look at the best this is the this
is the best version of Republicans on
immigration in the mainstream they say
uh we we we've got to stop this illegal
immigration because it's it's actually
bad for everyone including the illegal
immigrants and there's a lot of drugs
coming across and but we want more legal
immigration than
ever even Donald Trump the most
immigration restrictionist president of
my lifetime said
that he said we want we want more IM
imigration we just it's got to be legal
immigration but Mass migration including
legal immigration is a big part of the
problem especially when the federal
government starting under Barack Obama
can just wave the magic wand and turn
the illegal immigrants into legal
immigrants by declaration no no they're
no longer illegal they're dacka they're
no longer illegal they're dreamers
they're no longer illegal they're going
to have amnesty Ronald Reagan gave them
amnesty in the 1980s in exchange for
what he thought were going to be
concessions on border security and guess
what the latter never
happened we we have to be a little
clearer on
immigration and we don't need to take
the Democrats premise we don't need to
say oh yeah we're really racist we just
hate Guatemalans or something you know
yeah they don't we we prefer nicaraguans
we don't like Guatemalans and we don't
we like um I don't know liberians but we
don't like Ethiopians or no it's none of
that we I'm sure all these are great
people but a country has a right to
determine who comes into it and we have
taken way too many people and we're
having lots of trouble assimilating
we've known all the way back into
Antiquity going back to Plato and beyond
that migration causes lots of problems
in political communities and so you you
can do it and you can bring people in
and in a way you kind of have to bring
some people in but you've got to do it
in a very very intentional way because
otherwise you're going to cause all
sorts of so social disorder by mixing
peoples who come from totally different
Traditions who have totally conceptions
of public life and that's not just a
problem for the ones who cross the
border illegally it's true of all the
immigrants okay and so we want to take
some of them in we want to do it in a
way that is conducive to the flourishing
of the immigrants yes and of our country
and crucially here of the good political
party in our country the relatively good
political party because the Democrats
know right now that that the more
migration they get the the better it is
for them in the long term and so what do
the Republicans do to respond to that
they either are cowardly and they don't
say anything or and this might be worse
they engage in all sorts of happy talk
you get the line from Ronald Reagan
these Hispanic voters are just they're
Republicans they just don't know it yet
or well these you know you hear it today
these once in next election cycle once
the new migrants realize how corrupt and
evil and racist and bigoted and terrible
and mean the Democrats are then they're
all going to switch to be Republicans
and it just doesn't happen we're not
even just talking about the Hispanics
we're talking about all
migrants are there lots of great
immigrants who are conservative and
patriotic and
understand politics and have their heads
screwed on right and yeah of course
there's a lot but just as a matter of
Statistics as a numbers game immigration
is a net benefit for Democrats at the
levels that we're seeing today day and
so we can either be cowardly and not
talk about it or we can engage in the
happy talk and just pretend that next
election cycle magically everything's
going to turn around and all of the mass
migration is going to R down to the
benefit of conservatives it's never
happened before ever in all of history
but maybe it'll happen next time or we
can speak bluntly and say we like these
people we wish them well we actually
want some migrants to come into the
country but we've got to be very very
careful about it and not give the whole
country away not to the immigrants but
to the Democrats who are the ones who
actually pushing the policy because they
know it helps them we've got to protect
our resources all right our spiritual
resources our cultural resources and in
the case of your personal portfolio your
gold that's why you got to check out
Birch gold right now text nlls to 9898
98 as we head toward a presidential
election in November there's one thing
you can be sure of 2024 will be a
tumultuous year how will your
hard-earned savings fair you already see
the impacts of inflation at the pump in
the grocery store how are you protecting
your savings consider diversifying with
gold from the Birch gold group for
decades gold has been the choice of
investors and central banks to hedge
against inflation if you have an IRA or
401K from a previous employer that is
just Gathering dust call Birch gold and
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you won't pay a penny out of
pocket they will simply convert that
401k into physical gold which unlike
digital currency can't be tampered with
just text NS kwes to 9898 98 and Birch
gold will send you a free info hit on
gold with an A+ rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of satisfied
customers and the exclusive gold company
of the daily wire for the past 7 years
you can trust Birch gold to text Nes
kwes to 98 9898 to claim your free info
kit that is NES kwes to 9898 98 and
secure your savings now now the
question that that is a follow-up to
here's how we protect our elections from
rigging and the importation of Voters
the question that comes up is
do elections matter anymore anyway we
just had an anniversary a couple of days
ago what what is today today's today's
the 8th so that means that a couple of
days ago
[Music]
was January 6th the worst day in the
history of this or any Republic the day
the Democracy almost vanished from the
face of the
Earth and what happened on January 6
well it's a little controversial now if
you had asked people to 3 years ago they
would have given you one answer they
might give you a different answer today
there's a poll that just came out from
the Washington Post and University of
Maryland so not exactly right-wing
sources that say that
since January 6
2021 people have taken a decidedly
dimmer view of the legitimacy of the
Biden presidency they've taken a dimmer
view of the propaganda surrounding the
supposed terror attack Insurrection Ceta
that took place on January 6th three
groups were examined here on their
evolving views of January 6th
Republicans Democrats and independents
every single group today is less likely
to believe that the Biden election was
legitimate every single one it's most
pronounced among the
Republicans uh but you see it even with
the Democrats too 91% of Democrats say
Biden was legitimately elected but two
years ago 94% said that so 3% of
Democrats now think that Joe Biden stole
the 2020 election I know it's only 3%
that's a that's a big deal when you've
had non-stop propaganda and hearings
from Democrats and a couple fake
Republicans like Liz chany and Adam
kinziger when you've had the
prosecutions now of Donald Trump over
this you you've had a a constant
concerted media campaign to say 2020 was
the most safe and secure and wonderful
election ever Donald Trump is an evil
traitor insurrectionist secessionist if
we ever let him even close to the levers
of power again the country is going to
collapse and 3% of Democrats hear that
and they say ah n that's bogus nah Biden
probably did steal that election you're
right for for the Republicans 39% say
that uh Joe Biden
uh was not legitimately elected that
that's down to uh down from
31% um or I'm sorry 30 31% is down from
39%
66% of Independence say that Joe Biden
was legitimately elected that's down
from 72% that's a major major collapse
the conclusion here
is January 6th
totally
backfired
why nobody believes it it looks like
theater we have the security camera
footage which was finally released
because Republicans took power in the
house and it shows oh hold on the the
January Sixers weren't murdering cops CS
actually no no cop was murdered in the
the political violence of of January 6
no one was murdered whatsoever other
than one Trump supporter Ashley babbett
who was shot by a trigger happy cop who
faced no consequences actually it turns
out the horn hat guy didn't just kick in
the door guns of Blazing and take over
the the floor of either chamber of of
Congress actually he was a sced around
by police he was essentially given a
private tour of the capital actually
actually actually what we thought
happened did not really happen MSNBC
takes that and breaks down crying going
to try to get through this
um thank you for what you did three
years ago
today um please tell me your thoughts um
on this third
anniversary
um we are uh still in the midst of the
the same fight that
began uh on January 6th
2021 same fight thank
you on the third anniversary of this
hallowed day a day which will live in
infamy please tell us what happened
because we haven't we haven't heard the
truth about what what happened on MSNBC
ever on any of the mainstream news
outlets we saw the truth
on the security camera footage that we
had to pry from their
hands what on this on this awful
day in recent
history five members of Congress were
shot by Puerto Rican radical activists
in recent history The leftist Weather
Underground blew up part of the capital
in fact part of the capital has been
blown up like three or four times in
American history in relatively recent
memory
Not only was January 6th not the worst
Insurrection that ever took place at the
capital in the United States it wasn't
even in the top
eight it wasn't I don't think it was in
the top 12 and people wake up to
that in including some
Democrats when when you overplay your
hand when the Democrats think they can
overplay their hand because they control
all of the media and the universities
and basically every Center of power in
the country so they think okay there's
no lie so large we can't tell it but the
truth does break out every now and again
they don't have complete and total
hegemony and so when when people find
out that they've been lied to they start
to question everything they start to
question whether that election was
legitimate in the first place and the
fact that
now people are significantly less likely
to believe that the 2020 election was
legitimate that's not my fault that's
not your fault that's not the fault of
the conspiracy theorists and the
insurrectionists that is squ the fault
of the liberals who lied to us and
because they lied about that a lot of
people think huh maybe they lied to us
about the election too things are
breaking down the reason I bring all
this stuff up is not even to talk about
January 6 or Trump or 2020 or I it's
that the whole social order is breaking
down people see a riot at a shopping
mall they don't want to believe that
there are riots at shopping malls they'd
rather believe aliens are invading from
outer space in a way that's more
comforting
than just the sad predictable decay of
America as the greatest country in the
history of the world begins to resemble
the third world there was a crazy story
out of Alaska Airlines it came out just
yesterday an Alaska Airlines flight was
going from uh Oregon to California and
it takes off this is a 737 Max n it's
gaining altitude I think it was about
16,000 feet and the passengers hear a
bang they thought it was an explosion
and part of a part of a door like part
of the side of the plane just explodes
it just pops out some some person's
shirt is just ripped off of him a little
teddy bear goes flying out the
window and they need to make an
emergency landing luckily no one died
but you can see some of the pictures of
it it's crazy it's not even just that a
window popped out it's like a whole
little side of the plane pops out there
how does this kind of thing
happen
because forgetting about high philosophy
and political
ideology we are no longer good at doing
just the basic things to make a society
run if you've ever traveled in the third
world I was recently just in a communist
state I've I've traveled to multiple
Communist States one time I tried to
travel to another one and I found out I
was banned from that country that's a
story for another time but I've traveled
to more right-wing parts of the third
world I've traveled to communist parts
of the third world and the thing that
strikes you about it the the
distinguishing feature of these
societies that are just really broken
down and not functional is that it's not
really primarily about ideology it's
about does does the sewage run it's
about do the social services work it's
about can you trust that you're not
going to be mugged when you walk outside
it's it's that can you trust that if I
store my wealth in a certain place I'm
not going to lose all of my wealth can I
trust that the airplanes are going to
work and lest you think I'm just making
a mountain out of a mole hill and this
is an isolated incident it's really not
there's a a statistic that near run-ins
between commercial planes I'm not
talking about little dinky private jets
I'm talking about commercial aircraft
near run-ins or up 25% over the past
decade if you've been to the airport
recently you know
delays cancellations they're way way up
it's just we're just kind of breaking
down you can't run a society on radical
ideology for very long for two reasons
one because if your ideology is contrary
to human nature and reality it's it's uh
going to leave you uh constantly
frustrated by the chasm between your
fantasies and the the reality that we
all live in but but two if if all we do
is focus on this Pie in the Sky crazy
stuff you learn about radical gender
theory in school and you hear all of
these cockamamy theories H and and the
people who are indoctrinated into that
are the ones who go and run the
corporations and run the government and
run problem is they're not going to know
any basic technical skills to keep the
machine moving when you don't keep the
machine moving it breaks down now one
way if you want to keep yourself moving
you got to get a good night's sleep
that's why you got to check out
Helix right now go to helixsleep.com
Helix is the gift that keeps on giving
in fact I just set up another bed in my
house over the weekend for my eldest son
he's going to move from the crib to the
bed guess what kind of mattress he's
going to move on to you guessed it baby
a helix mattress Helix is now
introducing their newest highest end
collection Helix Elite Helix Elite
harnesses years of extensive mattress
expertise to offer a truly elevated
sleep experience the Helix Elite
collection includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences go to Helix sleep.com
kwes to check out the new collection
today nervous about buying a mattress
online you don't have to be Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else go to
helixsleep.com
kwes take their 2-minute sleep quiz find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type your mattress will come right
to to your door for free plus Helix has
a 10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they will
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will the financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20% 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to Helix
sleep.com
nkw use code Helix partner 2020 this is
their best offer yet it will not last
long with Helix better sleep starts now
speaking of basic things breaking down
this is a story from last week that I
wanted to get to that I'll take a little
time to do today because it doesn't seem
like it relates but I think it actually
does Kelly Clarkson has just come
out and given marriage advice Kelly
Clarkson is recently divorced so not
great to get marriage advice probably
from a recent divorce a she
says three things here that are totally
wrong one she says love is not forever
love is never forever you you know you
got to remember that going in two you
really want to make sure you're in a
position where you don't need anything
from your partner okay you don't want to
be dependent on them and three you just
got to go to therapy all the time
therapy is really really
great all three of those things are
totally
wrong I've always known that love is
hard for me love has always come with
this elephant and the room of sadness
I've known love is not forever I don't
mean that to sound depressing but I
think we put a lot of pressure on that
word sometimes love is looking at
someone and going this is not for you
this is not good for
me that's a hard thing to face but when
you do I think you grow yes you grow
very
sad but you don't you don't grow in that
you don't you're not edified by that
you're not Sanctified by that you're
usually you're you just left right back
at square one and then you started again
but is she said she said love is so sad
to me CU I know it's never going to
actually go anywhere we'll see how far
along it gets but then eventually one of
us is going to pull the pl plug that is
not the way to look at it that is the
way of looking at love as a matter of
emotion and Caprice and individual
preference that is not how our society
has traditionally viewed love that's not
how love actually works love is willing
the good of the other person for that
person's own sake love is an action that
we performed love is something that we
are commanded to do as Christians if you
were a Christian uh but I think we're
all commanded to do it actually by the
god of the universe
um you have to do it even when you don't
want to you have to do it even when you
just look at someone and you go this is
not good for you this is not good for me
yeah let's just quit no you still have
to do it when you make a commitment to
somebody you just have to follow it out
and and not only do you have to follow
it out in this this tedious way where
it's just drudgery and and and difficult
all day long you need to figure out how
to make it work and Thrive and if
something's not working right then you
need to to recognize that love is an
objective thing outside of your own
emotions and you need to do it and if
you are not perfectly willing the good
of the other person for that person's
own sake and vice versa then work it out
figure it out but otherwise you'll just
be left with what she admits is just a
big elephant in the room of sadness if
it's all just a negotiation and a Gamble
and and based on individual Choice
rather than objective reality between
the social animals between human beings
then it's always going to flop second
one dating sucks it's so awkward I was
single until I was like 30 and I forgot
how really good at that I am I told a
friend that a potential partner would
have to be an individual that brings
their own life to the table without
needing anything from me it's far more
romantic to say I want you but I don't
need anything what I'm really good right
now I'm having a good time what are you
talking about this is total Millennial
cope I don't mean to be too harsh on
Kelly Clarks in here but it's a
teachable moment and she's saying things
that are just completely insane I think
part of the reason that Millennials in
particular particular or having trouble
getting married is that people sometimes
we harden a little bit we aify a little
bit okay when you're young you know
you're really malleable you try on
different personalities you try out
different ideas you you're you're a
sponge you you learn new words and
behaviors it's easier to learn a foreign
language for example as you get older
you kind of aify a little bit and Harden
so if you're a little if you're a little
clump of putty you're 15 years old
you're a little clump of putty you got
your 15-year-old girlfriend she's a
little clump of putty and you're all
just a little putty and you get smooshed
together and then you start to harden
over you're going to harden into shape
with one another if you're your regular
clumps of putty and you're totally
separate an individual and you just
remain totally
alone you're going to harden into your
own shapes it's going to be a lot harder
to smash you two together okay there's
going to be little gaps there's going to
be little air pockets it's got little
parts are going to break off it's going
to be difficult I'm not saying it can't
happen I know plenty of friends who've
gotten married not just in their 30s
which is is now the norm but 40s
50s it can happen it's a it's a fallen
world and we do what we can but it's
going to be a lot easier you don't want
someone who is totally fully formed with
all of their own tastes preferences
beliefs behaviors every and then you
have exactly the
same when it comes to your tastes
preferences behaviors whatever and
you're just going to mash them up in a
kind of a negotiated partnership you
want to grow together is what you want
you want
your wife to be part of your flesh okay
another another part of you and you're
going to develop those things together
not you you want dependence you want to
share a bank account you want
to be together a lot you want to do that
otherwise it's going to be like an
you're running an accounting firm and
you've got to have board meetings every
week to decide basic questions third one
she goes I'm taking my power back that
sounds very therapy but that's because I
love therapy and I think it's important
to have these those tools to navigate
your life in
relationships how many people that you
know who who are constantly in therapy
are
happy not very many probably now you
might say well yeah that's why they're
in therapy okay how many people who are
in therapy for a really long time seem
to get
better very few I'm not saying it can't
happen it does happen Drew claven he
says he's the one guy ever in history
who got cured by a therapist and then he
stopped going to the therapist because
he got better I know people who go to
therapists for years decades they only
ever seem to get worse in some cases
they just use the therapist as a drug
dealer you know a psychiatrist okay get
me more depression pills or something
but in in some cases it it's a better
form of therapy which is cognitive
behavioral therapy or some kind of talk
therapy working through problems but
even then a therapist is only as good as
the premises he he brings to it right if
a therapist purpose starts with the
premise that there is no God there is no
soul you're just a bag of chemicals the
only purpose in life is to to amass
pleasure and we're going to look at the
world through the the Viewpoint of
hedonistic
utilitarianism okay you know I don't
think that's conducive to human
flourishing if your therapist comes in
and is a Christian and recognizes that
you do have a soul and that life is
about more than just feeling pleasure
and doesn't believe that marriage is
dissoluble and doesn't believe all this
non sense that Kelly Clarkson's been
saying then you're probably going to
have a better
therapist but which is it we just
because we live in such a uh decadent
and uh philosophically and theologically
shallow Society it's not that we got rid
of our priests it's just that we anoint
new people to be our priests you can
never get rid of the priests there is a
Priestly class in every society ever
throughout all of human history every
little no no two- bit tribe
in papaa New Guinea has some kind of a
priest class that's something that human
life demands we deny it we say we killed
all our priests we all the the society
will only flourish when we strangle the
last king with the entrails of the last
priest you know all this kind of
craziness that came out of the
Enlightenment and the French Revolution
and all but it's not true there's always
going to be priests there's this human
need and this this exercise of power is
always going to be there it's just going
to move around and we have uh anointed
therapists with a lot of that Prestige
from the Priestly class but what if
they're totally wrong what what if
they're not up to the job what if even
they they're very well- intentioned but
they don't have really solid thoughts on
theology ontology anthropology what
happens then you get a ton of Confusion
And you get a bunch of Feelgood you know
slogans that you could buy on one of
those signs they sell at TJ Maxx you
know and the and the the highest moral
theological Maxim that you ever here is
live laugh love live laugh love is fine
to spruce up you know a powder room it's
not fine to live your life by it it
doesn't it doesn't interpret itself and
it can lead you down this path of yeah
just do whatever feels good in the
moment thank you therapist see you next
time really really bad advice Kelly
Clarkson I have a soft spot for her but
that's terrible advice speaking of women
in Show Business whoopy
Goldberg has just come out to put a rest
to the
rumors she says yes there is a Jeffrey
Epstein list floating around and yes
she's on it but that's not the whole
story just because your name is on the
documents doesn't mean that you have
done anything criminally irresponsible
or illegal or civil irresponsible or
that you were a client or that you were
a client and so being named in this suit
does not equate to being accused of
wrongdoing and I think that is extremely
important because conspiracy theorists
seem to not understand or enjoy facts
yes these are the facts yes let let me
bring that up the conspiracy theory
folks
uh because you know I have to explain
because there was there was a fake list
yeah and I'm on
it so you you you you were on the island
I was apparently I I don't know I they
said I was on the island they said I'm
and I'm like I don't go
anywhere if the story about a
bus maybe but it's like you know so I'm
just going to say you know and there's
been a lot of stuff recently I don't
know what I've done to anybody but
apparently there are a lot of these
these kind of sites that are what do you
call them they're parody or they satire
sit sites but people don't realize that
they can be harmful oh yeah whippy that
sure sounds like the sort of thing that
somebody who is best friends with
Jeffrey Epstein would say hm this Whoopi
down there on the island with all that I
don't think so actually there are fake
lists I can't believe I have to agree
with The View today I don't think whoopy
was on Jeffrey Epstein's Island and did
weird stuff with Jeffrey Epstein I agree
with sunny hustin when she says that
just because you're named in the
documents doesn't mean that you did
anything wrong that's true you could
your name could pop up and you could
just be referenced by one of the many
powerful and important people that
Jeffrey Epstein knew so you know oh yes
we and got a sandwich at uh some rich
famous guy's house but the rich famous
guy never went to the island never went
to the tow houses never got weird
massages from the girls whatever I mean
even people have made a big deal about
Alan dtz the Harvard law
professor very famous American lawyer
and Harvard Professor uh and they've
insinuated that he was a client of
Jeffrey Epstein or something like that I
don't really see evidence for it
actually I know it's unpopular to say
but I I tend to give Professor dtz the
benefit of the doubt why dtz was
Epstein's lawyer Epstein had a lot of
money people who are accused of crimes
with a lot of money hire the very best
lawyers Alan dtz is one of the very best
lawyers in the country Alan dtz did go
visit uh Jeffrey Epstein's places that's
that's the sort of thing that a lawyer
does to his clients so I'm not I'm not
saying it's totally impossible but I I
agree there are there are people in
Jeffrey Epstein's orbit who probably
didn't do anything particularly
wrong there at least there's a reason
for Alan dtz to go see Jeffrey
Epstein why is Prince Andrew seeing
Jeffrey Epstein okay why why are some of
these other really powerful political
and financial and business figures going
to see Jeffrey Epstein they're the ones
who need to explain it but to whoopies
point and to the to the whole view
segment it's hard to believe what's on
the list the testimony that's come out
is just what someone says and maybe
that's credible but maybe it's not
credible and it was a long time ago I
don't care I I might be the only
conservative in America who doesn't
particularly care who is on the Epstein
Client List because I am much more
interested in who Jeffrey Epstein was
working for I said it last week I'll say
it again I'll sell say it till I'm bleue
in the face I think who is on the
Jeffrey Epstein list is a little bit of
a distraction yes the bad people who are
doing bad things on the island should be
brought to Justice they almost certainly
never will we'll probably never learn
their names but yeah in a perfect world
I'd like them to be brought to Justice
it is more politically relevant for us
to know what this operation was in
service of it was clearly some kind of
intelligence gathering operation the guy
had cameras and microphones all around
his homes he saved files we know this
from testimony he saved files of soand
so with some young girl you know in the
massage room over here they he labeled
the CDs and he had comprom on very very
powerful and important people again
whose names we likely don't know and
then we know that the FBI went in and
raided his place and then a safe went
missing and it just coincidentally would
appear to have been the safe with all of
that evidence in it I want to know what
was this about was Epstein working for
himself was that what it was in service
of just to get rich was he working in
service of a foreign intelligence agency
we know that Gan Maxwell's father was
probably a triple spy the the
British spy agency MI6 for whom he
worked also thought that that gilan or
that Robert Maxwell gilan's father was
working for Israeli intelligence that
one seems pretty clear and Russian
intelligence possibly the KGB I don't
know we know that Jeffrey EP forget
about the foreign intelligence we know
Jeffrey Epstein was connected to
American intelligence from the testimony
of Alex aosta the US attorney who
prosecuted him who then was up for labor
secretary under
Trump
that's yeah oh I don't know is whoopy
Goldberg like a a surprise sexual
deviant I I guess she could be I don't
really think she
is I think that's all a distraction and
and I think it's pointless anyway to
even inquire into it because we're not
going to get those not names they're
always going to they're always going to
pull the rug out from under us the thing
we have a better chance of figuring out
the thing it's much more politically
relevant what was the Epstein spy sex
ring
for you got to start 2024 off right en
join the fight to take back our culture
here at the daily wire we've got some
incredible things lined up for you this
year like the hilarious Mr birum our
first ever animated series featuring an
All-Star cast including Adam Corolla
Roseanne Bar Megan Kelly and more plus
our highly anticipated series The Pen
Dragon cycle and the 2024 election will
be one of the most pivotal in our
country's history the election wire is
your source of Truth bringing you
everything from the campaign trail to
the debates and election day and for our
younger audience daily wire Plus members
now can unlock our brand new kids app
benkey at no additional cost and of
course you'll be the first first to see
Snow White and evil queen featuring
Brett Cooper exclusively on bent key in
2024 your daily wi Plus Membership will
give you more of me which should be
enough for you you'll also get Ben
Shapiro Matt Walsh Candace Owens Andrew
claven Jordan Peterson Prager youu and
that is just the beginning this will be
the daily wire's biggest year ever but
we need your support join the fight to
reshape and take back our culture today
at dailywire.com
subscribe my favorite comment yesterday
or on Friday I suppose is from Devon
rosi who says since we won't be gathered
here on the 6th I just want to wish
everyone an early happy National guided
tour day yes and a happy one to you as
well speaking of pedophiles Jim Gaffigan
took the stage at the Golden Globes last
night it was a mixed bag of of an awards
show I certainly didn't watch the whole
thing I saw some of the clips going
around it it was worse even than usual
but there were a few bright spots
including Jim gaffan
who probably had the funniest line of
the night the Golden
Globes I mean
I I can't even believe I'm in the
entertainment
industry I can't I you know it's so
unlikely I'm from a small town in
Indiana I'm not a
pedophile you
know it's funny because it's true that's
that's what's funny about it
and it didn't totally kill they weren't
all just dying of laughter there they
weren't dead silent either though it was
just the sort of thing they could
chuckle about because they know that
there is a pronounced pedophile problem
in
Hollywood especially as a mackerel
snapping papist you know there was this
awful sex scandal with these Pedas
priests who were molesting boys and uh
it became international news for decades
which rightly should be the priest
should be routed out of course but the
thing that was unjust about it is that
uh Catholic priests are no more likely
than the clerics of any other religious
group to engage in that kind
of pedophilic sexual uh assault it it
was no more it was most pronounced and
the attacks on religion in our
civilization tend to be on the Catholic
Church which is the 2,000 year old
pillar of of the faith so you know even
in Hollywood we live in a Protestant
country so-called but every Hollywood
depiction of someone going in for a
really intense religious confession it's
always in a Catholic confessional
they're always talking a priests
there're always it it tends to come back
to that so even though other religious
Christian denominations and other
religious groups had it at a similar
rate uh the Catholics got the brunt of
it but what was even more unjust was
that put the religious groups decide
Public School teachers are multiples
times more likely to molest children
than any of the religious groups in the
United States Catholic certainly
included the public school teachers
because they're a favorite of the
Liberals they get totally off the hook
and then beyond the public school
teachers you've got Hollywood which has
a major pedo problem and they all know
it
including the attendees at the Golden
Globes perfect delivery and the delivery
was so calm and this this is something
that I think is actually a helpful
lesson in politics I was talking to a
friend of mine who's a little liberal
and gets really you know exacerbated by
politics said Michael how are you so
calm about
politics and I I think there is a a bell
curve in terms of political knowledge
and experience that will determine
whether you are calm or
crazy the people who don't know know
anything about politics who have no idea
what's going on they never read a
newspaper they well if you read a
newspaper you probably don't know what's
going on either but you know they're
just totally disengaged they're very
calm of course they don't have anything
to get crazy about then when you start
reading the papers a little bit you know
and you start paying attention to some
of the corruption in our politics and
you start noticing that the guard rails
might not hold that well and our
institutions are are crumbling around us
you you start to get kind of crazy you
start pulling your hair out and then
when you keep reading all that stuff but
you also read how politics has worked
for all of human history and you start
reading you start reading history a
little bit and you start reading
political philosophy and you start
recognizing that that some of these
problems just appear to be intractable
in a fallen world and they get better
and worse and they often come in cycles
and even when you got a really good time
for a few decades the bad times are on
the way there you start to get calm
again this stuff has happened even the
most horrific kind of stuff you know
we're the stuff that Jim Gaffigan is
joking about at the Golden Globes or the
the nass massive corruption going on at
the highest levels of the federal
government they say yeah this has all
happened before got to fix it got to do
our we got to do our level best to fix
it but this isn't
unprecedented this isn't totally
shocking this is actually kind of how
the world works and had had we just
opened our eyes and allowed ourselves to
dispel the propaganda and just seek
clearly what's really going on we could
have expected it a lot of people don't
want to believe that our country could
could decay in the same way that every
great Empire has ever decayed they don't
want to admit that if there's a riot at
a shopping mall it has to be an alien
invasion not us not our country no way
uh maybe every other Empire and Nation
not us no us too we can maybe turn it
around but we've got to be honest first
we got to see the truth first now
speaking of guys who are really good at
this be guys who are really really good
at just staying calm cool collected
seeing a little bit ahead of the curve
and acting on the political sphere and
having good effect Chris
rufo probably the fa there were other
people behind it but Chris rufo is the
leading figure in the movement to oust
Claudine gay the president of Harvard
because she was a plagiarist the real
reason is because she said that it was
okay to call for the genocide of the
Jews during a congressional testimony
but that's what weakened her they still
weren't going to totally throw her out
the plagiarism Scandal CR up as as an
academic matter that's actually a more
egregious Scandal rufo claims the scalp
the president of Harvard's gone and now
everyone's going after rufo and and my
favorite attack on this
guy comes from within Harvard because
Chris rufo he he graduated from
Georgetown that's where he went to
college and then later on he got a a
degree at the Harvard Extension school
and the Harvard Extension school is one
of the schools of Harvard but it's kind
of like the night school you know or the
online school it's the one where you go
and you take some classes and it's
certainly non-traditional but it's a
school of Harvard University you get a
Harvard University degree at the end of
it now the libs are attacking him and
they're saying he doesn't have a real
Harvard degree it's just from that that
extension school that's the fake Harvard
degree and this is such a perfect story
it's it's so classic Chris rufo it's
so I don't it's so leftist in a way it's
so clever in in how Chris has now put
his opponents in an impossible situation
because either they have to admit that
Harvard degrees can be worthless we were
told that a Harvard degree is the most
important and impressive thing ever all
the big fancy Libs who run everything
they all have Harvard degrees and they
say that that is one of the credentials
that shows why they ought to run the
entire country well hold on you've just
admitted either that a Harvard degree
can be worthless or you've got to admit
that Chris rufo has the same degree that
you guys have and so so he is worthy of
the same respect that you have which is
it uh I don't
e what's funny is the actual answer is
both of them which is Harvard degrees
are increasingly worthless all of them
not just the extension school but all of
them and also Chris ruo is worthy of
much more respect than you know the
right- wiers who are actually trying to
uh help resuscitate the country are
worthy of much more respect than the
libs with all of their fancy degrees who
have destroyed it so you actually can
have both but right here what are the
libs going to give up The Prestige of
Harvard
or the ability to marginalize prominent
right-wingers which one are they going
to give up they don't want to give up
either really they've got to give up
both the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code nolles kwl at check out
for 2 months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
yeah